on Friday two days after a tragic road
rage shooting in Albuquerque anti-gun
New Mexico Governor Michelle Grisham
exploited the incident to issue an
emergency declaration curtailing the
exercise of the second amendment by
suspending conceal carry in Albuquerque
for 30 days which is of course a very
bad thing and here's her
reasoning you took a oath to the
Constitution isn't it unconstitutional
to say you cannot exercise your your
carry license with one exception and
that is if there's an emergency and I've
declared an emergency for a temporary
amount of time I can invoke additional
Powers no constitutional right in my
view including my oath is intended to be
absolute there are restrictions on Free
Speech there are restrictions on my
freedoms in this
emergency this 11-year-old and all these
parents who have lost lost all these
children they deserve my attention to
have the debate about whether or not in
an emergency we can create a safer
environment because what about their
constitutional rights I took an oath to
uphold those two and if we ignore this
growing problem without being bold I've
said to every other New Mexican your
rights are subrogated to theirs and they
are not in my view wait a minute about
crimes there are already laws against
the crimes so how are there right but
but again if I'm
unsafe who's standing up for that right
if this climate is so out of
control somebody should do something I'm
doing as much as I know to
do mad govern do you really think that
criminals are going to hear this message
and not carry a gun in Albuquerque on
the streets for 30 days
uh no but here's what I do think it's a
pretty resounding
message to the lawful gun owners so we
all agree very bad this power grab is
extremely dangerous but here's the butt
what's even more dangerous this is this
is the butt that got me in trouble on
Twitter over the weekend what's even
more dangerous is that the governor of
New Mexico actually has a point and the
longer conservative refuse to
acknowledge this fact the longer we're
going to keep getting rolled by these
liberal power grabs which will only
continue to increase in frequency
severity and Injustice if all the
conservatives can muster to stop them is
a historical whining about abstract
rights which do little more than make us
feel good and righteous all the way to
the goog I'm Michael nolles this is the
Michael nlls
Show
[Music]
CO's happening again you want to talk
about emergency Powers being invoked
unjustly coid is happening again high
schools are cancelling their football
games because of coid this after the
mask rules in California in Atlanta in
Jersey this after the White House
telling you to get the VAC they're just
doing it again and they're doing it
because of the election we'll get to
that in just a moment first though a
related story I guess I got in so much
trouble on Twitter over the weekend for
saying something that is just obviously
true here's what I said I don't I don't
want to misquote Myself by even one
syllable I said unpopular opinion civil
leaders do in fact act have emergency
authority to suspend temporarily many
legal
rights that's true and my point being
that the New Mexico Governor is wrong in
particular here one because as that
reporter pointed out the criminals
aren't going to stop carrying their guns
because of this emergency declaration
two because the uh people of New Mexico
the law-abiding people of New Mexico
actually need a gun more than ever they
need to be able to carry a gun more than
ever because of the insane amount of
crime in Albuquerque and three because
the incident that took place in the road
rage though tragic does not constitute
an emergency so that's the reason why
what she did is wrong but she's only
wrong in particular she's not wrong in
principle and conservatives oddly enough
seem to be misunderstanding this but the
point I was making that civil leaders
have emergency Authority temporarily to
suspend
rights that is not a particularly
controversial point point of view I mean
I guess it is now but it has never been
controversial throughout all of American
History throughout all of the political
history of the entire West on on either
side of the aisle or any of the the
different political uh participants in
our country the the basic principle has
often been articulated in America as the
Constitution is not a suicide
pact in other
words all legal rights are important the
law is very important up to and
including the Constitution but when the
whole of the law is threatened then a
rigorous meticulous adherence to the
letter of every single individual aspect
of the law is actually going to
undermine the law because you could lose
the whole law and the whole political
order to Anarchy or to I don't know an
Insurrection or an invasion I guess
those would be the extreme cases where I
think everybody has to Grant my point if
the United States were suddenly invaded
well I guess we are being invaded if the
United States were being more obviously
invaded and there there were
or there were a major Insurrection not
some Midwestern Granny's at the capital
but an actual
Insurrection would would martial law for
instance be called for yes of course
would you would you rather throw away
your whole system of law because you're
going to uphold every single little
statute everywhere or no would you take
care of the problem and then bring back
the
law I think we all agree if martial law
is a thing that exists and has been
exercised a number of times in American
history by some presidents who we like
some presidents who we don't like
then the principle holds true you
wouldn't want to give away the whole of
the law a a good piece of evidence that
my view is not so crazy is that Ted Lou
who's one of the most lib frustrating
members of Congress out there tweeted
out he said this order from the governor
of New Mexico violates the Constitution
no state in the Union can suspend the
Federal Constitution there's no such
thing as a state public health Health
Emergency except to the US constit
exception to the US Constitution so Ted
Lou is saying no no no we have to always
rigorously follow the letter of the law
I guess Ted Lou now supports conceal
Cary that's great I don't I didn't think
he did but I guess he says that he he
does now David hog who's that like
12year old I think now he's like 30 but
he started out when he was 12 David hog
is this anti-gun campaigner says I
support gun safety there's no such thing
as a state public health emergency
exception to the US
Constitution so the fact that two huge
Libs are on one side of the issue and I
a conservative are on the other side of
the issue some people took this to to
mean that the world has gone crazy and
can you believe it even David hug even
Ted l no they're they hold this view
because they are liberals because
they're extreme
liberals and I hold this view because I
am a conservative this view though has
been held by conservatives by liberals
by everyone going back Thomas Jefferson
probably said it most clearly Thomas
Jefferson wrote in 1807 on great
occasions every good officer must be
ready to risk himself in going beyond
the strict line of the law when the
public preservation requires it his
motives will be his justification pretty
that's a pretty strong statement his
motives will be his justification there
are extreme cases where the laws become
inadequate to their own preservation and
where the universal recourse is a
dictator or martial law so lest there be
any confusion as to how far Thomas
Jefferson who is probably our most uh
open-minded classically liberal founding
father he said No at certain points if
the whole of the law is threatened if
the whole of the nation is threatened
then you've got to take care of the
emergency and then go back to the law
Jefferson went on further a strict
observance of the written laws is
doubtless one of the high duties of a
good citizen but it is not the highest
the laws of necessity of
self-preservation of saving our country
when in danger are of a higher
obligation to lose our country by a
scrupulous adherence to written law
would be to lose the law itself this is
almost exactly what I just said with
life liberty property and all those who
are enjoying them with us thus absurdly
sacrificing the end to the means and
Jefferson finally says the line of disc
discrimination because some people are
going to say well how do you know when
it's really emergency how do you know
this won't be exploited Jefferson
addresses this he says the line of
discrimination between cases may be
difficult but the good officer is bound
to draw it at his own Peril and throw
himself on the justice of his country
and the rectitude of his motives wasn't
just Jefferson uh John uh uh Hamilton
and Madison made similar points in the
Federalist John Adams exercised a not
not quite suspension of the law but a a
strong uh circumscription of the law in
the Alien and Sedition Acts a strong
curtailing or limiting of the First
Amendment uh you saw obviously Abraham
Lincoln suspended habus Corpus uh
generally we like Adams I think most
people like Abraham Lincoln it's been
used by bad presidents too uh Franklin
Roosevelt and woodro Wilson but it's
been used a lot we we've had martial law
declared in the United States on a
number of occasions because of war in
the case of the City of New Orleans
during the Battle of New Orleans we
we've had it declared during uh natural
disasters uh Great Chicago Fire 1871
there there are some other ones 1906 San
Francisco earthquake Omaha race riot 201
1920 Lexington riots so where does this
idea come from it goes back even earlier
than Thomas Jefferson it goes back to
this notion that uh the the welfare of
the people the good of the people is the
highest law salus populi suprema lex
this is a law that comes from Cicero in
ancient Rome Cicero on the laws but it
was rearticulated by none other than
John lock the father of liberalism
Classical liberalism a man who was
fairly influential though his influence
has been exaggerated but fairly
influential in the American Revolution
he wrote this as the epigraph to his
second tretis on government this is John
Lock's most famous book he said that
this is a fundamental rule for
government but that is the highest point
of the law some people point out they
say well Michael where in the
Constitution does it say that there's an
exception to
this first of all it's alluded to in uh
in at least two parts of the
Constitution but even let's go beyond
that for a second if the exception were
included within the text of the statute
the law or the Constitution it would not
constitute a true exception we're
talking about something at a higher
level than than the mere text that's
what Jefferson's talking about that's
what John Lock is talking about here
that's what cico is talking about and
and in fact this principle has been
upheld by the Supreme cour court or at
least articulated by the Supreme Court
on at least two occasions explicitly in
1949 and 1963 Supreme Court decisions
explicitly said the Constitution is not
a suicide PCT so why do I bring it up
because I said at the beginning I'm not
bringing it up to justify the New Mexico
Governor's actions I said in the case of
what she's done this is
wrong but it's wrong for different
reasons than we conservatives are saying
and I think that I think the reason that
Ted Lou and David hog are on one side of
this argument and I'm on the other is
not because the world has gone crazy but
it's because the Liberals don't want
conservatives to recognize this point
that when the whole of the law is
threatened it is not only our right but
it is our
responsibility to in certain narrow
extreme cases go beyond the mere letter
of the law to save the whole of it the
the most perspicacious response to my I
thought basically uncontroversial point
on uh Twitter was that they said wow it
was a liberal who said it the liberal
said this New Mexico Governor's decision
was so moronic because it's going to
empower conservatives to begin to
exercise this line of thinking and I
think that's the
point we
conservatives in traditionally have
always been pretty practical you know
pretty grounded in reality pretty
focused on tradition and history and how
the law actually works in the last few
decades we've gotten very ideolog
logical we've taken a ton of bait from
the Liberals and so now we speak in
these abstract rights almost exclusively
and in it in a way that's ahistorical
and in a way that is not very effective
because we can whine and scream and we
say this is hypocrisy what she's doing
this is unconstitutional this isn't
right we have our rights and that's
going to be the Epitaph on the
gravestone of conservatism imagine if
the shoe were on the other foot imagine
if we did this well no she in principle
her point is right and we should fight
her on the particulars this is not an
emergency this is not going to help
anything this we should fight her in
court I don't think this thing is going
to hold up and then we should also
exercise the the correct principle that
she is here
exercising in what case would you say we
would do that well I mentioned earlier
that an invasion would be a good example
of a time when we could uh go a little
beyond the ordinary operation of the law
because an invasion threatens our entire
political order it threatens the whole
of the law unfortunately we have not
been able to stop the Invasion on our
Southern border because every time even
Donald Trump who was really relatively
strong on this when he would try all of
a sudden the the mechanisms of the
bureaucracy and the supposed meaning of
the strict letter of the law said no you
can't stop an invasion of foreigners
into your country now Trump managed to
get around this one time and you know
how he did it by curtailing suspending
the ordinary operation of the law
through title 42 he said okay the libs
are going to declare an emergency with
Co I'm going to use that emergency with
Co to greatly reduce the flow of illegal
immigrants into the
country very important and then the
Biden Administration runs and they say
we're going to get rid of that title 42
perhaps if
conservatives would stop believing a
bunch of
hogwash about American history I mean
the notion that so many conservatives
didn't understand that the constitution
is not a suicide pack tells me that even
on the right forget about the people on
the left who are very confused about
American history even many people on the
right believe a whole thought lot of
things about American history and
government and political philosophy that
just aren't true a lot of us believe
fairy tales that were invented in the
middle of the 20th century that America
is a fundamentally liberal democracy and
America how we there's there are no uh
complications to any of our abstract
rights or anything like that that it's
just not true and it has really hampered
our ability to wield political power
effectively this woman knows how to
wield political power now I think she's
gone too far I think she's wrong in the
particulars I think this is going to I
don't think she'll be able to extend
this after 30 days she might not even be
able to make it the full 30 days and
even if she does it'll be litigated in
court and it's a it's a one aspect of of
a hotly debated part of the second
amendment I don't think this is going to
be the end of the world for New Mexico
it's a it's a stupid decision but it's
not going to be the end end of the world
but the principle that she's
articulating if we were to accept it
would perhaps allow us to get around the
very unjust wielding of the strict
letter of the law on legitimate National
emergencies I'll leave my point at that
one thing we can also do to strengthen
our country pray which is why you got to
check out hallow right now go to
hall.com there is no better time to
build a daily habit of prayer and
meditation building habit of prayer can
help you cultivate an attitude of
gratitude focusing on what you are
thankful for can increase positive
emotions and improve overall well-being
also you owe prayer to the Lord your God
so you need to pray hallo is the number
one Christian Prayer app in the United
States it has helped countless people
maintain a daily prayer routine and it
can help you too download the app for
free at hall.com noes you can set prayer
reminders and track your progress all
along the way not sure where to start
check out father Mike schmitz's Bible in
Year my favorite podcast available on
the Hallow app for brief daily readings
and Reflections or pray alongside Mark
Wahlberg Jim cavel and even some
worldclass athletes with hallow you can
customize a personal prayer plan that
works for you listen wherever you are
with downloadable offline sessions using
hallow to connect with others who share
your beliefs and values can provide a
sense of belonging support and Foster a
sense of community and you will learn to
be a better person in today's broken
world right now go to hall.com try three
months for free hall.com
they're they're going to invoke National
emergencies this was the the craziest
response to to my tweet is that someone
said Michael how could you still believe
that that civil leaders have emergency
Authority after the experience of
coid to which I said that's proving my
point they did they did wield that
emergency Authority during Co and
they're doing it again and they're doing
it again they're wrong on the
particulars but they're right in the in
the principal that's how they're getting
away with it and you're seeing it
they're bringing it back two California
high schools just canceled their
football games because of coid esparo
high school which is located west of
Sacramento canceled its football game
which was scheduled on uh last Friday
because six
players caught coid allegedly Santa
Paula high school north of La canceled
its Friday football game also against
laata high school he of 20 positive coid
cases on the football and cheerleading
teams it's happening
again and so the the question for
us is either we can whine and complain
and say you know actually in
1792 the the founding fathers didn't
believe the framers didn't believe that
that these local people would have this
Authority which by the way isn't even
true they act the founding fathers and
the framers thought that and exercised
those rules even then actually probably
more uh audaciously than we do today
than even the fouches of the world are
doing today so we can make that argument
and it's not going to get us anywhere or
we can go on offense and we can engage
in the substantive debate and we can win
we do have an example of this the
example of this is Ronda santis in
Florida Ronda santis has given a very
good uh road map of how to do this which
is he's not just going to say look uh we
don't care uh what the students learn
only that they learn you know we don't
care what they think just how they think
no no Ronda santis goes into schools and
he says hey we're going to set standards
we're going to ban books from school
we're going to ban certain stupid fake
lessons we're going to set the
curriculum and we're going to set on the
question of coid we're going to set the
mode by which we're going to live with
this Co virus we are not going to start
canceling things we're not going to shut
down businesses there are going to be
some Floridians some liberals who claim
that that it's their right as a matter
of public health for businesses and
churches to be shut down yeah we're not
going to do that we're setting the rules
coid is not dangerous enough you have
plenty of ways to avoid being out in
public if you don't want to be around
coid but we are not going to allow some
minority of idealogues to upend our
entire way of life here in Florida this
ties in with what we were talking about
last week this uh best-selling Italian
book that got its author an Italian
General fired because it was Politically
Incorrect that had to be self-published
even though it's a huge bestseller and
the book talked about the the
dictatorship of minorities we're not
just talking about religious minorities
or sexual minorities or or uh racial
minorities or but minorities as a
concept an ideological minorities who
upend all of our culture and we
unfortunately conservatives in the name
of some hyper individualism some Embrace
of liberalism for some reason that
that and a liberalism that doesn't even
Define our country and our civilization
we say okay let them do it you do you
I'll do me we have no rights to any kind
of collective or uh Community standards
no DeSantis said no way okay and he he's
been pretty successful because of that
that might be a way forward and when you
want to set limits around who sees what
you on your computer you got to check
out expressvpn right now go to
expressvpn.com going online without
expressvpn is like leaving your kids
with the nearest stranger while using
the restroom would you ever do that I
should hope not most of the time though
you'd say it's probably fine but you
never truly know who it is you're
trusting so why would you risk it that's
why you need to be using expressvpn
every time you connect to an unencrypted
Network cafes hotels airports pretty
much any network that's not your own
your online data are not secured any
hacker on the same network can gain
access to and steal your personal data
your passwords your financial details
you name it expressvpn creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so that hackers can't steal
your data hackers can make some serious
cash selling personal info on the dark
web however expressvpn has made it
easier than ever to keep your
information safe just fire up the app
click one button you are instantly
protected works on all your devices
laptops phones tablets so easy that even
I can use it go to expressvpn.com get
three extra months for free
expressvpn.com
expressvpn.com slns to learn more
speaking of the
election got some spicy stuff is this
going to get me kicked off YouTube this
isn't weird sex stuff so it shouldn't
get us kicked off YouTube
but it it this isn't the uh explanation
of fundamental truths about anthropology
so I don't think this should get us
kicked off YouTube but it is about the
2020 election John Eastman was one of
Donald Trump's lawyers John Eastman I
know that Trump had some eccentric
lawyers on his team in certain places
John Eastman is a very serious man this
is a a very serious legal scholar he was
the dean of Chapman law school he's uh
associated with the Claremont Institute
he is a wonderful guy and he believes
that the 2020 election was stolen and
that is why he
proposed uh various legal and political
strategies to uh stop what he believed
was the Democrats from stealing the
election so we've always heard since
20120 no there's no evidence that the
election was stolen this they never made
their claims in court part of the reason
that the Trump team never was able to
make the claims in court is because
courts wouldn't hear the cases courts
didn't want any part of this I remember
Justice Scalia making this point after
the 2000 election which was another
contested election people didn't go to
jail for that one but that's that's
because it was the Democrats contesting
the election anonin Scalia said you want
to blame the Supreme Court for deciding
Bush Vore we didn't want to decide Bush
VOR no we didn't want that case you
forced that case on us we would have
been happy to stay out of it so the
courts wanted to stay out of it too we
are now finally getting some information
though about the 2020 election some of
the arguments for how it was stolen
because John Eastman is on trial and so
what did John Eastman do in the trial on
Friday he had uh Michael gaan who's
Wisconsin Supreme former Wisconsin
Supreme Court Justice testify in this
California State Bar about a legislative
audit that he held of the 2020 election
and this this investigative report that
the former Supreme Court Justice
presented to the Wisconsin State
Assembly showed irregularities including
dropboxes absentee ballots and he
concluded that the legislature could
desertify the election
conclusions
so the the judge in this case who's
overseeing John Eastman's uh trial about
whether or not he'll be
disbarred the the judge doesn't want
gableman to be making this these claims
so the judge in the case is telling the
Wisconsin Supreme Court Justice no
you're not allowed to talk about the
widely held view that the assembly
speaker Robin Voss in Wisconsin didn't
want quote a real investigation into the
election and granted limited funds for
the effort the the judge in this case
Roland struck that part of the testimony
gableman then responded to the to the
judge in this case and said do the rules
of civil procedure do the Rules of
Evidence apply in this court what do you
mean I'm not allowed to present evidence
I thought that's the whole reason I'm
here in the court the judge ordered a 5
minute recess and said you know
basically hey defense you got to get
your witness in line here what else did
did the Wisconsin Supreme Court Justice
find uh found that Zuck bucks Mark
Zuckerberg's money where Mark Zuckerberg
said I'm going to spend a ton of money
to prevent Trump from being reelected
Zuck Buck's contracts required cities to
follow instructions provided by this
Shady left-wing organization called the
center for Tech and Civil Life which the
Justice uh believed was a violation of
law because it was a private entity
telling the government what to do uh now
the center for Tech and Civil Life who's
it funded by it's funded by the skull
Foundation democracy fund Knight
Foundation new Venture fund hope well
fund Rockefeller Brothers fund these are
all left-wing organizations uh the ctcl
was allowed to see uh voters who had
requested ballots but had not returned
ballots so it gave this left-wing
organization a complete view over what
was going on in real time in the
election this is something that no other
group no other political group would
have been able to have that the the
conservatives certainly wouldn't have
been able to have the the ctcl employees
were embedded in Clerk's offices they
were essentially running the elections
and gableman said that votes were
illegally cast because the drop boxes in
which those votes were cast were
violating the law because they weren't
near the clerk's offices they weren't
near the clerk's offices because the
ctcl this left-wing group dictated where
the boxes went in violation of the law
so those were not validly cast ballots
that's just one example then the Racine
County Sheriff referred charges to the
County DA regarding election officials
who were breaking the law da said she
wouldn't bring the charges she said she
didn't have enough resources to bring
the charges completely BS excuse gaban
then said he looked into the electronic
voting machines and had serious concerns
about them this is what he said I don't
want to be slapped with any lawsuits
here defamation BS left-wing operations
I'm just reporting to you what the
former Wisconsin Supreme Court Justice
said and testified in the court on
Friday so this is just news don't shoot
the messenger he said that voting
machines Dominion was the main one but
then also esss and Hart were quote the
opposite of cooperative and quote
hindered my ability to get to the truth
of whether whether there is fraud in the
machines and fought us every step of the
way with lawsuits to stop the team from
finding out if they had safeguards
pretty pretty strange behavior wouldn't
you say for an election that was totally
on the up and up and uh Gable one said
he found uh very concerning pieces of
information but nothing he could totally
put together or say without any shadow
of a doubt but things like Wi-Fi
connections to the internet how the
machine counted the ballots by taking
images and converting it into
mathematical formula so that you'd end
up with things like fractional votes
just a lot of issues and then you have
just the broader statistical issue Trump
won 18 out of 19 bellweather counties in
2020 there we we think that the election
is determined across the entire nation
it's not it's determined by a handful of
counties that in recent decades have
have decided which party which candidate
is going to win the election in 2020 18
out of the 19 counties that typically
would decide the election when for Trump
one of them went for Biden yet Biden
wins the election kind of weird now you
know I hate to say I told you so I think
among conservatives in the media I have
been one of the more uh open and
suggestive voices when it comes to
whether or not the 2020 election was
stolen and the evidence presented at the
uh disbarment trial for John Eastman
would seem to back this up but still
it's up in the air we'll see how the
testimony goes and even at this point
doesn't really matter because Joe Biden
was able to take power and wield that
power effectively but it does get back
to the point that we were raising about
emergency powers and whether this the
constant adherence to the strict letter
of the law is really in service of the
law most broadly which the Liberals are
currently arguing it is the
conservatives uh traditionally have have
observed that obviously it is
not one of the objections that people
made to my point was well where in the
constitution is this exception well
where in the case law is this exception
and I've pointed to parts of the
Constitution and I've pointed to parts
of the case law but even beyond that I
guess my response as pertains to the
2020 election and the 2024 election
is where in the constitution do you find
the compromise of
1877 this is something you may or may
not have learned about in high school
history class Compromise of 1877 was you
had the presidential election in
1876 you had the Republican ruford B
Hayes you had the Democrat Sam Tien
and they couldn't decide who won the
election because there were some
allegations of voter fraud there were
competing slates of electors it was a
very similar situation to what happened
in 2020 so similar in fact that Senator
Ted Cruz in 2020 suggested the creation
of an electoral commission to decide
that election as took place and to
decide whether or not to certify the the
elector
votes as took place in
1877 and the reason it was controversial
when Senator Cruz said it and the reason
it was controversial in 1877 is it's
nowhere in the Constitution nowhere in
the Constitution now we're in article
two does it say that the way to solve a
contested presidential election is to
set up this random commission with
people from different parts of the
government to kind of vote on whether or
not the uh the ballots should be
certified and what happened in this
Compromise of 1877 which wasn't written
down anywhere by the way the compromise
of 1877 was kind of a handshake deal in
a back room with probably a lot of smoke
going around was that the Democrats
would agree to give the election to
Republican ruford Hayes if the
Republicans agreed to pull troops out of
the South and stop reconstruction and
let the Democrats run the South that
that was the deal nowhere in the
Constitution and you might say well
that's a rotten deal it's
unconstitutional it's a violation of
Rights but then my question
is what was was the alternative what was
the Constitutional alternative there
wasn't one it was a constitutional
crisis it was a national emergency and
when the strict adherence to the letter
of law is insufficient to solve those
crises when the therefore the whole of
the law is threatened by those crises
people need to get a little bit creative
that's what happened then and it's
nearly what happened in 2020 the
Democrats just had enough power that it
didn't really matter
but folks the reason I bring all of this
up I think I've made it clear as day I
don't I'm not talking about the New
Mexico lady I'm as strong a defender of
gun rights as possible I think she's
going to lose as she should we are
hurtling toward a 2024 presidential
election at a time when neither party
believes in the Integrity of our
electoral process at a time when there
are still lots of questions about
whether or not our electoral system has
been so weakened by the laws and illegal
procedures that the libs put into effect
just a few years ago and by the way
they're doing it again already by trying
to bring back the exact same excuse of
coid we can deny this we can keep our
head in the sand and then the Democrats
can steal the election and then we can
complain about it or we can get a little
proactive here and recognize that we are
facing a fairly significant likelihood
of yet another constitutional crisis and
we're going to need a game plan for how
to deal with that or once again the the
Epitaph on The Headstone of conservatism
is going to be well here lies
conservatism imagine if the shoe were on
the other foot imagine if the roles were
reversed I don't think it is fully
appreciated how far beyond the law the
libs are willing to go here there's a
report that just came out the Georgia
grand jury that indicted Trump and his
lawyers and I don't know like his cook
not really his but just so many people
who were even vaguely associated with
Trump Georgia wanted to indict more
people Georgia wanted to invite sitting
US
senators the the grand jury recommended
charging 21 people who were ultimately
not charged there were already what 19
people charged Trump and 18 codefendants
they wanted another 21 they wanted to
indict uh former Georgia Senator David
Purdue wanted to indict former Georgia
Senator Kelly leer wanted to indict
sitting US senator Lindsey Graham
and I know some people don't like
Lindsey Graham so they probably want
Lindsay but I I kind of actually get a
kick out of Lindsey Graham and in any
case no good argument for this random
County in Georgia to indict a sitting US
senator from South Carolina completely
insane they wanted to indict former
Trump National Security adviser Michael
Flynn and then Fanny Willis the
prosecutor here didn't she she only
indicted 19 people including the former
president of the United States and the
leader of the opposition wow that that's
moderation from the left yeah we're not
going to start inditing senators from
other states in this random County yeah
we're not going we're only going to
indict the leader of the opposition and
anyone who's even vaguely associated
with him folks we are
in pretty much Uncharted Territory here
the whole thing the indictments totally
Uncharted
the former president running for a
non-consecutive second term that's only
happened one other time in American
history the complete upending of our
election rules based on this
virus that's fairly
unprecedented there is no script to
follow here okay and a
myopic insistence on well just show me
exactly where in the strict letter of
the there is
we're we're writing the script right now
sorry let me rephrase that the script is
being written right now as to how these
elections are going to take place the
script is being written right now as to
how power is actually going to be
wielded in the United States States we
are not writing it because we're living
in a fantasy world the left is writing
it and so long as we don't accept
political reality basic historical facts
of of politics basic philosophical
truths of politics and just the news of
what's going on right now the longer
that we don't accept that the less
likely we will be to have a share in
that power in the future my favorite
comment on Friday is from ASMR
conservative who says
I actually appreciate the ADL they had a
lot of conservative pundits on their
watch list so I figured I'd check them
out here I am now thank you I know this
is how I feel about the ADL to some
degree I mean there the ADL is is pretty
bad in that they they call people Nazis
if they don't just totally cow toow to
to the radical left-wing demands of the
ADL and they're trying to take down
Twitter so I think they're particularly
a threat right now and Elon is right to
Su them for defamation it's very funny
some of the others are pretty bad too um
right-wing watch people for the American
way is is pretty people for the American
way the most ridiculously named
organization in American history um
they're pretty bad Media Matters is
pretty bad I
just my my hold up there is the same
point that you've just made which
is I really hope Elon doesn't kick off
Media Matters or sue them they have been
my loyal publicists for years at this
point what seven eight years at this
point um I don't want to get new
publicists I really appreciate them they
watch the show every day they're
watching right now so it's true
sometimes these guys the libs are so
wrong-headed they think they're going to
kill us and they only they only make us
stronger all right speaking of
Elections Nancy Pelosi who is by my last
count 584 years old she is running for
re-election Nancy tweeted Out quote now
more than ever our city needs us to
advance San Francisco values and further
our country yeah yeah we we need drug
addled bums defecating on the street
from Sea to shining sea that's what we
need we need two cars in every garage
and a syringe in every pot that we need
San Francisco values in America uh our
country needs America to show the world
that our flag is still there it's a
rainbow flag by the way it's not the red
white and blue they got rid of that one
but the rainbow flag is still there with
liberty and justice for all that's why
I'm running for reelection and respect F
ask for your vote Nancy and now look
especially depending on what happens in
2024 it's going to be very dangerous for
Nancy Pelosi to be an office because she
remembers the compromise of 1877 so
she's going to be able to wield power
very effectively uh I don't I don't mind
that she's running for reelection it's
not good it's bad but I kind of get a
kick out of some of these Old-Timers who
have been these women of a certain age
and some of the oldtime or male
politicians who have been around forever
Bernie you know all of them they're
going to hold on as long long as they
can the people are allowing them to hold
on okay that's just how politics Works
however I will
say the longer the geriatric politicians
hang on the more massive the political
sea change is going to be once they
inevitably have to leave office because
the old Grim Reaper finally shows
up it that's just a fact they can hold
on in both parties Nancy Pelosi can hold
on Mitch McConnell can hold on Joe Biden
can hold they they going to hold
on we we had what a we had a boomer
president in Bill Clinton Boomer
president in George
Bush I thought a boomer I thought a Gen
X president in Barack Obama some gen
xers have written into me screaming and
said Michael how dare you associate him
with
us Obama is technically a boomer okay so
fine Canam is a boomer then another
Boomer president with Donald Trump it's
four Boomer presidents and then Joe B
who's the silent generation who was
before the baby boom so these guys have
held on to power for an extraordinarily
long period of time and all that means
is that the Next Generation that comes
up is going to be that much more removed
is going to differ that much more from
the views of that previous generation
but there's no there's no stopping
change forever it will have to happen
time rolls on History rolls on you look
right now at Hungary a government that a
lot of American conservatives quite
admire because it's the only country
that's been able to turn around its
birth rate problem the only country
that's been able to stop Mass migration
the only country that's been able to to
rebuy its cities it's the only it's the
only country where the cities are
getting more beautiful not uglier and
part of the reason they've been able to
do that is the government is quite young
in Hungary it's a vibrant young
government that's not just stuck with
the old platitudes of the 1980s but is
is think applying Eternal principles to
to the new circumstances that confront
us um that's going to happen here
eventually it's going to have to
when that grip of power runs out and
this is why I would encourage
conservatives not just to recite the
same platitudes that you learned in 1982
platitudes which may or may not have
even been true
then you know politics often boils down
to talking points and talking points are
always wrong because they are always
oversimplify they never tell the whole
story sometimes they outright lie if we
just keep rehearsing the same old script
that we learned in 1982 we're going to
keep on losing just like we have since
1982 almost without exception
or we can use our imagination we can dig
into history we can dig into philosophy
and we can and we can imagine we can
think about what the future looks like
and bring that to effect speaking of
geriatric politicians Joe Biden is
slumping among non-white voters which is
a big problem because the Democrats rely
on a total lock on racial minorities so
if they lose the racial minorities
especially black voters uh they they
could lose basically every election this
is according to CNN and SSR RS shows
Trump is up one over
Biden um so for the people who say Trump
can't win you know again that was
disproved by history because Trump did
win in 2016 and maybe who knows who
knows what happened in 2020 uh Biden is
hitting his targets among whites so
Biden is matching 43 44% of decided maor
major party white voters that he won
last time but he's he's losing some
non-white support meaning that he's not
he's not behind on non-white voters he's
still massively ahead on non-white
voters he's just not as far ahead as he
was last time so Joe Biden still wins 58
to 34 among non-white voters according
to Nate con of the New York Times but
because he's lost some ground this could
could be a big problem for him uh Trump
for instance got 29% of the Hispanic
vote uh in 2016 that was compared to
Romney's 27% of the vote so this is very
funny that Trump who called Mexicans
rapists and murderers was able B to do
better among Hispanics than milk toast
nice nice sounding Mitt Romney it really
upended a lot of the chattering classes
you know establishments uh anti-trump
rhetoric in 2016 but still 29 versus 27
it's not it's not a lot it's it's fine
and and Trump does better among
non-white voters than most Republicans
he got 8% of the black vote compared to
6% that Mitt Romney got okay that's fine
but this also highlights the political
importance of immigration for whatever
reason Republicans just don't do that
well with non-white voters that is why
the Democrats are flooding the country
with illegal aliens because they are by
and large almost entirely non-white
immigrants and they're not doing it
because they care about the Venezuelans
or the Hondurans the poor people
crossing the border paying off the
cartels to be smuggled and raped and
trafficked and and sometimes killed
along the way they're just doing it
because it swells their numbers and it
swells their numbers in a whole lot of
ways it swells their numbers in Congress
because Congressional apportionment the
number of districts that that a state
will get is based on total population
not based on citizens so you flood the
country with illegal aliens millions and
millions of year that's going to
increase especially in Democrat places
like California it's going to increase
their representation it's going to
increase their their representation in
the Electoral College it's going to
increase their proportion of the voters
it's go it's it's helping them this is
not something where we can say Well in
30 years hopefully we'll just pass a law
and you know the Hispanics are
conservatives they just don't know it
yet some of them are and it actually
varies by nationality Cubans tend to be
much more Republican than say voters
from I don't know
uh Venezuela say or Guatemala um and the
children of these immigrants and the
grandchildren of these immigrants but by
and large there's still
anti-conservative they still go for the
Democrats this is an emergency because
well we can be chattering about the
precise application of the rule of the
law and whether title 42 is acceptable
or not should we really arrest these
poor people fleeing the persecution of
what there they're seeking persecution
by signing up with the cartels while
we're while we're debating that the
country is being radically transformed
as an intentional program by the
Democrats to swell their numbers and to
to make the Republicans a permanent
minority forget about racial minorities
cultural minorities religious minorities
it just as an electoral matter that's
what the Democrats are after here are we
just going to let that happen or are we
going to are we going to get creative in
how to enforce the law at the very least
the highest sense of the law in spirit
the rest of the show continues now folks
it's music that you don't want to miss
it become a member and use code NES kwes
at checkout for 2 months free on all
annual
[Music]
plans